[Musique]
c'est mon école là où je passe le plus
clair de mon temps
[Musique]
ma salle de classe
on est les plus âgés de l'école
[Musique]
avant on était comme ses enfants on
s'amusait comme m mais quelque chose a
changé
je sais pas trop quoi on a tous peur de
quelque chose et ça c'est la bande
d'amis elle est pas aussi stupide que ce
qu'elle prétend mais les gens
intelligents ne sont pas sexy et il n'y
a rien de plus important que je pense
que c'est elle cette eau va parfois elle
est alignée dans le cercle magique 2007
vous lui d'ennemis choisir les garçons
décident si vous êtes six souffre cette
nouvelle il ya quelques années on ne
voulait rien avoir à faire avec eux mais
maintenant loudun et ses potes font la
loi
il décide si vous êtes assez bien ou pas
mais rien à faire c'est 1,3 minable mais
selma l'opinion des geeks ne compte pas
de quart et celui dû tuer rouge l'autre
belgique comme les eaux
tout le monde dit que c'est le meilleur
de la classe mais en fait c'est le mois
elle s'est seulement elle essaie d'être
cool les filles deux groupes pourraient
être copine avec le geek mais les geeks
veulent pas
aujourd'hui je sais pas trop où me
placer dans tout ça peut-être que les
autres non plus après tout ça c'est moi
ça a peut être l'air nul d'être moi mais
je ne voudrais pas être mieux les vendre
mon âme comme ça mais au moins elle à
l'heure de sa musique
je parle jamais beaucoup j'ai presque
oublié le son de ma voix à l'école tout
ce que je dis c'est salut merci au
revoir mais je me démarque des autres
parce que je réfléchis beaucoup par
exemple je m'étonne que cet endroit
précis puisse mener n'importe où toutes
les routes mènent à d'autres routes
[Musique]
ça veut dire qu'on est tous connectés ou
qu'on soit sur terre quelque part sur ce
réseau je grandis en silence
mais j'observe beaucoup c'est pour ça
que je peux vous raconter cette histoire
à cet instant précis
je ne doute pas que tout va changer
[Musique]
tout ce que je peux faire c'est attendre
que les événements surviennent comme
vous
[Musique]
notre constitution a été rédigé pour
protéger nos droits inaliénables
quelqu'un peut-il me donner un exemple
de droit inscrit dans la constitution
suédoise le droit de fumer de baisers de
bois qu'en penses tu me diras tu dois
bien avoir une petite idée
qu'est ce qui est crucial pour le peuple
dans une démocratie liberté de parole
bravo liberté d'expression entre la
liberté d'expression est un droit
protégé par la loi liberté d'expression
excellent exemple
mais est ce que vous savez au moins ce
que ça signifie hilda la liberté
d'expression c'est exactement ce que je
viens de faire là c'est vrai mais qu'est
ce que ça implique vraiment en détail tu
en penses quoi victor on peut dire ce
qu'on pense qu'on saura seulement ce
qu'on veut oui ou ce qu'on aime bien
selma tu pensais à autre chose on peut
aussi on peut aussi écrire ce qu'on
pense absolue c'est ce que nous avons
tous le droit de nous exprimer sans
aucune censure d'écrire ou de dire ce
que nous voulons c'est un de nos droits
constitutionnels le plus important mais
nous avons d'autres droits
constitutionnels lesquels intéresse est
ce qu'on a le droit d'aimer qui on veut
c'est dans la constitution la liberté
d'aimer c'est la classe témoin pas dans
ce pays on peut aimer qui on veut cet ex
même si c'est pas réciproque
l'amour n'est pas garanti mais chacun a
le droit d'aimer qu'il enfilait mais
c'est quand même mieux si c'est
réciproque
howlett en pense quoi de tes mais
réciproquement
mais tout le monde t'aime que tu le
veuilles ou non tout est grave
tu m'étonnes mais si on préfère que
quelqu'un nous déteste on a le droit de
pas vouloir son amour ce problème n'a
rien à voir avec la loi ouais mais dans
certains pays et mis quelqu'un c'est
puni demander la raison dans certains
pays l'amour obéit à des lois mais
ensuite vous avez le droit d'aimer qui
vous voulez les machins des sentiments
qu'appartiennent c'était un exemple mais
tu peux si tu l'aies mme may a qu'un
pervers qui aime un cheval c'est
vraiment l'esprit mal placé le nez - son
refuge en tic doit aller on se détend si
vous n'avez pas le droit d'aimer un
chemin c'est comme un chaton c'est
mignon on peut aimer des poulets aussi
si on veut ce n'est pas du tout le sujet
d'aujourd'hui est levé la main avant de
parler
c'est pas le sujet t'as pas compris ma
fille j'ai dit poulet d'abord et puis
c'est toi qui a commencé à souffler
maintenant sinon ça continue alors
quelles sont les autres droits
constitutionnels de la suède
léo liberté d'information d'association
liberté de religion sont les piliers de
notre liberté d'expression en tant que
droit excellent léo excellent
[Musique]
du
tous trop mignon ça fait des siècles
qu'on n'a pas fait ce genre de truc tu
t'en souviens si on a fait ça ils savent
même pas la chance qu'ils ont ne
grandissait jamais
[Musique]
honnêtement je prends ça pour une
véritable chance comme professeur de
tous vous voir progresser depuis toutes
ces années je vous regarde et je me dis
waouh c'est tellement cool que vous
libériez toutes vos inhibitions avec
tant de couleurs de formes doutaient de
perspectives de structure
vous nourrissez vos individualités c'est
si tu vas arrêter maintenant
c'est un miracle pour moi qui viens tous
les jours et qui vaut la peine qu'on
s'intéresse il a pourri mon dessin est
pardon pardon je m'excuse faut-il que tu
en perds tout véhicule à bas sur ce
monde est sain il fait exprès pour
m'énerver
tu es vraiment que j'étais pokes et pour
ça rien du tout et juste à gros pot via
s'est excusé tu doit pardonner sa faux
mais j'avais fait ce dessin pour ma mère
mais les bras quand même il est jolie
comme c'est ça il est tout nu ne
t'intéresse ça suffit maintenant on ne
fait pas le bébé l'école ce n'est pas un
endroit pour pleurer qu'est-ce qu'elle
gaming par faut tout ça pour de la
troupe soit tu comprends rien d'accord
c'est l'heure de ranger jeune joueur
racé vos pinceaux et vos palettes
nettoyez vos bureaux si par hasard vous
avez fait des tâches que tout soit comme
vous l'avez trouvé des restes tu va
nettoyer mon bureau vous salue et bonne
journée
c'est presque morte d'un kg est miami
heat a dormi à tuer illumine mes
journées je me sens vivant quand je te
vois chaque soir il faut que je me
dépêche d'aller à la cantine parce que
ce midi y a de la classe
on se reverra vite ma prof d'arts
plastiques préféré à plonge
ok le 10 mai au prochain concours tu
nettoies
sur le milliard au revoir à bientôt
mais regardez moi que ce foutoir roger
tout avant de partir les filles ne
laissait pas ça comme ça mais si on
travaille toutes ensemble on y arrivera
aussi niais est ce que tu peux ne peux
pas laisser ça dans cet état merci merci
quel frêche s'en fout les filles
je
salut les filles aujourd'hui c'est
hachis parmentier vous allez voir et les
délicieux
une part pour toi bon appétit massy du
hiv s'il mangeait bien manger tout
manger tôt
il ya de la glace encore non il y en a
plus mon petit chou mais si tu veux de
la glace il faut arriver à l'heure
[Musique]
non
vous
[Musique]
ma métaphore avec un réseau de chemins
c'est parce que je suis allé au kenya
une fois tout ce que les enfants
voulaient là bas c'était un grillon un
crayon pour l'école pour pouvoir écrire
mais j'en avais pas avec moi j'avais un
appareil photo mon portable et mon ipod
c'est étrange on habite sur la même
planète
à la même époque
[Musique]
on
l'histoire n'a pas encore vraiment
commencé la vie suit son cours sans
qu'on se pose de questions on pense que
tout est émulé on se fait une idée de ce
qu'est la vie et on l'acsel telle
qu'elle est on flotte
on se laisse bercer par le courant ça
c'était avant
quand on était innocent
[Musique]
mais on a grandi
on
il maniait comme un tag
oh certes r d dans les yeux et c'est
devenu carrément dingue alors premier
roi de suède en 1852
[Musique]
premier règne au sein de ce groupe 1465
1466 erik xiv 1560 michel polnareff
c'est qui ça c'est qu' elle qui sait
salut tu es dans notre classe j'ai
l'impression tekki d'abord à bienvenue
saga allez tout le monde en classe
gaffney bonjour
bonjour les filles bonjour allez vous
asseoir bonjour asseyez-vous bonjour mes
agneaux et à personne bon aujourd'hui
vous avez une nouvelle camarade dans
votre classe son nom et sa gare ring
elle nous rejoint pour le reste de
l'année tu es la bienvenue saga merci
est ce que tu veux bien te présenter un
petit peu aux autres où tu préfères que
je le fasse à ta place située un peu
intimidé je vais le faire ce cas est
bien d'accord si vous préférez non non
devant c'est bien je t'en prie merci je
m'appelle saga je n'ai jamais été à
l'école en suède avant mais dans plein
d'autres endroits
je suis allé à l'école par exemple à
cuba la barbade kenya et l'inertie en
tunisie est un peu en uruguay
une aventurière oui avec mon papa à
cause de son travail on doit beaucoup
voyagé comme ma maman est décédée
j'étais une petite fille et papa a voulu
aller voir le monde on est resté
longtemps aux caraïbes
c'est pour ça que la majeure partie de
mes études je les ai faites à cuba et
aussi bien sûr et la barbade cuba tu
parle espagnol
oui mais à la barbade il parle anglais
sérieux la barbade
ouais en afrique en parler aussi anglais
puis on est allés vivre à montevideo
montevideo sait où ça en uruguay où
est-ce que c'est lui d amérique du sud
et te voilà à la maison louis on a passé
du temps sur la route et maintenant on
rentre pour préparer le lycée est donc
ta mère est morte t sue c'est ce qu'elle
a dit oui tu as des frères ou des soeurs
non aucun mais pourquoi tu reviens là
c'est trop mortel à barbe av
il se trouve que les écoles et s'ils
sont vraiment bien n'est ce pas et puis
j'ai ma famille après tout c'est chez
moi je suis heureuse des revenus merci
saga c'était très intéressant de nous
faire partager ton parcours si atypique
j'espère que tu vas te plaire ici que tu
te sens la bienvenue
et que tout se passera pour le mieux
[Musique]
et je suis minute et saluons s'intéresse
à moi c'est linda à l'essai s'invente
pas refoulé un oui c'est le meilleur ou
la barre et trouver le meilleur c'est
une bonne nouvelle s'écrient c'est à moi
que tu laisses tellement ça lui seul -
salut c'est comment ton prénom et je
m'appelle signé je m'excuse d'avancé je
pense que j'aurais du mal à retenir vos
prénoms féminins titre souvient non
voici comment sais pas si c'est mieux
[Musique]
regardez moi toutes ces gauches il y en
a pas c'est quand même j'ai un groupe
des imbéciles qui a décidé de préparer
le concours de la fringue la plus large
du monde tu veux voir ma roue ça
t'intéresse qu'est-ce que tu coup moi je
cours je garde les tre place et tu vas
là m
ben oui pour le bal de fin d'année tu
veux voir la mienne oui je les travaille
ça c'est pour le des études ou pas trop
bonne idée est-ce qu'il faut taper dans
les lycées qui a filé à mimi et leur
personne enfin pour l'instant
mais quand tu voudras ce sera moi sa
copine tu as quelqu'un monténégro
montevideo qua non personne de spécial
je vais plusieurs elle a tout vu dans
cette salle en russie
ça c'est la classe le prof date du moyen
âge j'arrive toujours pas à croire qu'il
est marie miley pas mariés mais une
bague pour faire semblant
toi aussi tu arrêtes pas de faire croire
que tu es ma came florian ses influences
et imaginaire est nommé amis au kenya a
déjà un enfant non elle a le même âge
que nous elle a 16 ans et elle vit dans
le désert et elle doit porter l'eau des
kilomètres jusqu'au village préfère
finir tout seul plutôt que de vivre ça
ici c'est la classe de chimie
il est des trucs sur route on va aller
s'éclater à gaza
elle habite en ville avec le courant
[Musique]
comme ça tu peux discuter mais ton avis
du kenya et de cuba de cuba de tunis et
de la barbade et je les rencontrerai ils
ne sont pas connectés tisser
pour ressembler à quelqu'un du kenya
l'intérieur ils sont pareilles on a le
même coeur les mêmes certains allaient
même virus mais un liste principale
saluer et du coup sur coup
toi aussi tu étais au kenya trop mais je
voulais justement de parler de ce que
j'avais vu la voir aller vite possible
[Musique]
bon qu'on va manger ici stabilité salut
saga je suis le guide du réfectoire
je m'appelle ludwig une manuelle b-king
lmp si tu aimes les raccourcis tu peux
m'appeler lève mecheri de la cantine je
vous présente sa gamme
elle nous vient direct du droit de la
jungle elle n'y connaît rien de rien une
nouvelle alors bienvenue puis si je
m'appelle kerstin c'est moi qui m'occupe
de la cafétéria et tu allergies pourquoi
certains enfants ont parfois des
restrictions gluten lactose thomas elle
mange que des noix de coco et du serpent
elle a peut-être une arme aussi cacher
sur elle elle vient direct des
bidonvilles d'amérique du sud
sa vie se résume à la vente d'armes et
la drogue sont là je te jure
tu as l'air de trop les télévisions on
vide la même façon qu'en suède a
peut-être chez ce prêt de tu sais moi je
suis vraiment vite
vraiment je serai vite par un dans une
matière type ans si je te dis donc tu
mange de tout homme et oui bien sûr ces
tables tu as les salades et les boissons
sont disposés là bas on est tu peux
reprendre autant que tu veux vraiment
oui il faut bouger ou de tout pour bien
grandir le jour tu posera le pied là bas
ils te vole automobile est un ipod et il
est super en rampant par terre en plus
grand pour voir ta mère encore une fois
on est y sera foutu bon appétit
je foutrais pas les pieds chez les bois
un mois elle a vécu chez des bourrins
quoi
oui
saga vient s'asseoir ici tu peux y aller
à ce pape et répète vient à cette table
je m'assois celle là mais vous venez
normalement - ja notre table cet homme
là c'est la nôtre on vous avait des
places attitrées
non mais mais leur aval l on mange ici
ça change
donc on se met où on a envie ouais mais
mais on a là aussi s'appelait louis et
puis la nourriture à l'air excellente et
encore ta patience aujourd'hui ces
poissons panés labat a vu des gens
pauvres parfois oui à montevideo par
exemple il ya beaucoup d'enfants
orphelins
on leur donnait de la soupe et aux sdf
ont donné la fin de nos repas quoi et il
y avait même des jeunes mamans permis
avec les pauvres
bien sûr la vie est injuste en fait les
pauvres on pense jamais à vous allez
rien manger d'autres ya rien dans vos
assiettes
tu voudrais devenir grosse en afrique
que j'aime les femmes qui ont des formes
temps un scellement prend un billet il
serait fou de toi en afrique
comment y sont les africains ils sont
gros si c'est tout ce qui vous intéresse
quoi les garçons et l'apparence physique
vous aimez rien d'autre et qu'est ce
qu'une mal à ça rien tout va bien
personne ne pense que là d'où tu viens
on y pense tous c'est un fait elle ne
faisait pas le problème mais la vie
offre d'autres plaisirs du genre plein
alors heureusement que tu es revenu pour
nous apprendre lévis
non je vais rien de tel à tuer la saga
salut est-ce que ça se passe bien
- oui merci prenez bien soin de la
nouvelle ligne
on lui a fait faire toute la visite de
l'école super très bien et vous manger
ensemble maintenant c'est une bonne
nouvelle sa part fait appeler t il
d'accord c'est bien que tu sois dans
notre classe c'est la meilleure classe
l'école est super
[Musique]
salut salut mini écoute et il faut que
tu saches un truc que tu sais pas à un
truc important pour moi
tu es tu veux très bien car moi commence
à traîner tu veux l'être dans ma bande
de quelle bande tu parles
ben est ce que tu veux être mon ami mais
je le suis déjà oui oui mais oui mais
quoi je veux dire avec quelle bande est
ce que tu voudras trenet c'est quoi
cette histoire de bande à choisir mais
faites est complètement débile qua non
c'est juste que je comprends rien mais
disons tu peux pas être ami avec la
terre entière
bien sûr que si mais c'est pas possible
c'est comme ça moi je suis fais tu vois
ce que je veux dire quand même non non
disons ben disons les choses franchement
je suis la plus ces mois là c'est toi la
plus quoi laisse-moi rythme
la vie est ce qu'elle est ici et tout le
monde est ravi de comment les choses se
passent et on veut tous que ça reste
comme ça c'est tout ce que je voulais
que tu comprennes n'en est pas là
revient avec nous avant et vous aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'au la foule qui se
balance allez allez c'est pas la balle
malibu leslie quinton salut salut saga
des gt en tenue nous tenons ces réunions
de temps en temps pour pouvoir discuter
de choses importantes parler de choses
qui se sont passées ou ou des événements
à venir de bonne chose ou pas de la vie
dans la classe tout ce genre de choses
nous le faisons à chaque fois en petits
groupes pour que chacun ait son mot à
dire bien la séance est ouverte
nous sommes seulement entre filles oui
en fait nous séparons nous faisons deux
groupes distincts entre les garçons et
les filles
il semble qu'il soit plus facile
d'aborder certains sujets sont garçons
autour ils peuvent parfois être un peu
moins fort moins six religieux c'est ça
non non non mais les filles sont plus
silencieuses en présence des garçons
qu'est ce que vous êtes d'accord
on peut en discuter
est ce que vous en pensez non mais vous
n'avez pas parfois l'impression que les
garçons prennent trop de place est celui
qui donc personne ne partage mon
impression pourtant les autres
professeurs le ressentent aussi la
plupart du temps les filles vous laisser
les garçons vous dominez moi c'est comme
ça que je le vois c'est tout sauf gênant
disons que moi je vois pas ça comme un
problème j'ai l'impression qu'il ya que
toi que ça embête et pour les autres
c'est un problème qu'est ce que tu en
penses ciller
c'est un problème
c'est parfois gênant ça c'est parce que
c'est toi c'est tout c'est pas du tout
comme tu le crois bref c'est génial tu
vas vas-y je peux aller à l'infirmerie
j'ai une migraine d'en faire moi aussi
moi aussi oui moi aussi
non
[Musique]
petit garçon qui se promenait avec son
besoin uruguay ouais c'est trop triste
il n'avait pas de maison et la pauvre
petite maman tout seul à qui vous
donniez les rays oui devant le
restaurant elle était tellement contente
qu'elle en a pleuré des larmes de joie
doussain pour verez et le petit ils
habitaient tous et dans un parc sous un
banc tout seul la nuit dans un horrible
car il a pâti chanson tout - je l'avais
quelque chose il fallait l'adopter quand
on y réfléchit c'est vraiment 30 jeux
s'imagine pas avoir de maison rappelle
où la petite fille qu'ils pouvaient pas
aller à l'école
ouais elle devait devenir prostituée
quoi et j'étais obligé ça arrive partout
dans le monde
c'est tellement injuste c'est un juge sa
mère heureusement c'est moins festif
mais c'est le quotidien
on rallume les lumières allez on se
réveille et bout là dedans
bien que pensez vous du comportement
animal sont ils tellement différente des
comportements humains
quel est le rapport je te rappelle plus
tard ciao des allées remarqué comme dans
chaque espèces les mâles doivent se
battre pour avoir des femelles
mais pourquoi se bat-il de toute
évidence s'il le sait pour se taper une
femme
le mâle victorieux obtient deux jumelles
femelle exact le mal le plus puissant à
la meilleure femelle est ce que cela
s'applique également aux humains ou
alors est-ce que nous sommes différents
de la honte écoute me laisse penser à un
truc dit le avant d'oublier un rapport
avec ce qu'on vient de voir
bah oui évidemment alors nous écoutons
tu dis que bien que les mâles se bat et
que les femmes poirotte et attendre
qu'un mal les choisissent c'est comme si
tu disais qu'on n'a pas de cerveau et
qu'on peut pas choisi mais le cerveau
d'une éléphante est plus gros que le
tirer est ce que tu peux être un peu
plus clair
mais c'est toujours comme ça qu'on nous
présente mais si ça se trouve c'est
exactement la verse de ça si jamais il
se battait pour qu'on choisisse celui
qui a le meilleur adn disons qu au lieu
d'attendre qu'on l'a choisi
elle les fait se battre pour choisir qui
sera le bon et alors plus hachée mais
est ce que je perçois tu viens juste de
dire deux fois la même chose mais avec
une autre en france ouais mais c'est
différent
la façon dont il présentait macho mais
tout le monde le dit comme ça disons ma
façon de le dire et tout civil dire
absolument comme tu veux mais on parle
de la même chose
ouais et qua non c'est pas mais ces
coupes mais je te jure que nous mais me
tu racontes la même chose mais je t'ai
dit mens pour les femelles
ça fait une énorme dit mais tu rêves tu
veux nous faire croire que les animaux
ça pense que veut leur donner le droit
de vote s'éloigne du sujet chalmé ben un
peu de calme on se concerte c'est mieux
j'ai quelques questionnaires ici à vous
faire passer ce dispositif les animaux
c'est comme les êtres humains peut-être
que c'est vraiment les femelles qui
choisissent le mal qui le plus fort si
tu as quelque chose à dire faisant
profiter tout le monde me latu ma cible
ok d'accord ça vous ennuie que j'ai
raison il n'y a pas de raison que j'ai
pas raison dix ans enfin bref je pense
que je vais voit la super vous devez
écrire cinq phrases pour chaque réponse
à me rendre demain et je veux des
réponses personnelles ce qui veut dire
que vous devez penser par vous même
tu es une excellente élève c'est
étonnant dans toutes les matières tu es
heureuse dans cet environnement
oui ça va tu t'es fait des amis oui un
excellent yat-il sujet que tu voudrais
que nous apportions tu peux y aller non
tout va pour le mieux
roma bon alors tout va bien d autres
profs sont ravis
je voulais te dire que nous sommes tous
et moi le premier
vraiment très heureux de t'avoir dans
notre classe tu répondre une sorte de
joie autour de toi tu exerces pouvoir
positif sur les autres filles de la
classe
est-ce que tu l'as remarqué elles ont
besoin d'un modèle d'une icône suivants
parce qu'elle laisse les gars ont dominé
l'école si je puis dire
elle ne se bat pas pour trouver leur
propre place c'est pour ça que l'effet
que tu produis sur elle est bénéfique
les professeurs en ont parlé et nous
avons besoin d'une fille forte un peu
dans ton genre une personnalité
je voudrais que tu considère ça un peu
comme une commande présenté comme une
mission
il est évident au vu de ce qui se passe
depuis que tu es là que tu peux avoir
une influence positive sur les filles de
l'école nous sommes vraiment heureux
d'avoir ici sa gamme
[Musique]
salut c'est marcel saga elle saga
schalit salue sa garde il ya quelque
chose que je veux te dire je je sais pas
comment le dire mais je pense que tu es
c'est trop mortel que tu sois venu dans
notre classe tu t'étais vraiment tu t'es
là mais hier je voudrais te ressembler
tu es tu es la meilleure de l'école
merci
mais j'ai dit un truc méchant à saga
c'est à ton ton salut selma bon alors
tes résultats sont vraiment excellents
la meilleure note dans tous les tests et
toutes tes missions et ben continue
comme ça mais il y a quelque chose qui
me chagrine un peu j'ai l'impression que
tu est extrêmement silencieuse
est ce que tu veux en parler
[Musique]
ouais
bien parfait ça va être l'heure de
ranger et de nettoyer assurez vous que
tout est propre
quand vous partez victor d'une étoile
classement dont c'était le dernier coup
vos reyes bon appétit à tous
l'us millas merci loudes et huard à 7 et
un saut je te verrai dans une semaine
j'entends leurs déjà tu vas manquer si
j'en ai jeté demander quelque chose et
j'ai pas le temps mais on se parle par
sms ou qu'on y ayuda je peux pas désolé
j'ai beaucoup trop de choses à faire
adios mis aux normes
et regardez moi ce que nous ont laissé
les hommes il ya l'eau partout par terre
c'est l'enfer à signer et bonjour moi
tout ça regarde moi cette horreur de
talent at il faut la lave et essaye de
nettoyer tout ça ça gabon non je te
demande pas dans gm ferait rien voyons
il faut s'entraider un peu oui mais je
ne nettoie pas la merde des autres biens
et selma occupe temps et ida et alicia
et d'émirats avec les tables cette
classe est un foutoir
vous travaillez pour l'école où vous
êtes leurs esclaves
qu'est-ce que tu es un signe ça me
choque de voir les antilles fifi
nettoyer la classe après les cours elles
ont la gentillesse d'aidé au lieu de se
plaindre comme une sorcière c'est normal
selon toi que la moitié de la classe
s'en aille et que le reste nettoient
leurs tables qui en est responsable
comment tu abandonné des camarades
pendant qu'elle nettoie la classe c'est
leur problème pas le mien je vais faire
vous pouvez y aller allez sortez
[Musique]
question suivante qu'est ce que le pib
kelly ouais j'en sais rien léo la somme
de la valeur des biens et des services
pendant un an excellent et que
signifient les lettres pib hilda et à
s'indigner bord n'est pas drôle d c'est
vulgaire linda c'est le produit
intérieur brut
et quand représente-t-il chaque part de
la population samuel sais pas j'ai pas
levé la main oui quoi il s'agit du pib
domestique j'allais le dire bien par
quel autre terme peut-on définir ou
plutôt mesurée par habitant la richesse
ou la production d'un pays
qu'est ce tu té i dh mais vas-y ray pour
moi ton tour saga saga je veux que le de
me répondre
quel manque de respect à ton tour que
j'interroge d'accord bien que signifient
les initiales idh idh de développement
humain mais ferme la veux tu as compris
c'est quoi le problème
tu répondras quand j'ai tenté roseraie
en attendant j'interroge loudet et c'est
à lui de répondre tu m'entends crav
c'est bon tu peux y aller une des parts
quoi mesure-t-on l'idée h je sais la
santé mortalité infantile niveau d'étude
égalité des sexes
veux-tu te ra soir à la place est-ce que
tu as perdu tu es bonnes manières
pendant tes voyages hippies tu dis moi
excusez moi monsieur je te demande de
t'asseoir cash vainement assieds toi
tout de suite avant que je me fâche
c'est comme ça qu'on parle ça suffit
maintenant tu ta siège est une bouche
plus je recommence à des vosges entre
toi tu la fermes et harry bon c'est ce
contenu ludek poids devrait du mois
quels sont les bénéfices du pib
le pib mesure le bien-être économique
tandis que les idh mesure le bien-être
humain leur qualité de vie
car sa ferme la [ __ ] va bien le faire
faute petit con et répond au moins elle
bat qu'elle le fasse quand c ar youdé
connais pas la réponse de toute façon
d'ailleurs tu sais jamais rien mais pour
qu'elle se prenne faut lui laisser sa
chance mais la réplique c'est plus un
modèle n'était pas son tour ses clients
à qui voudrait se concentrer cette
[ __ ] dans cette carte je vous en prie
ne manquons jamais eu un problème de
discipline avant ce choc et de la teneur
de césium la classe chez les filles on
se tient debout et gaza
tc vous qu'est ce que c'est que cette
façon de se tenir
saka écoute moi bien je ne veux plus que
tu répondes avant que je m'interroge et
je suis sérieux
mais comment ses troupes un geste les
garçons passent leur temps à le faire et
c'est thierry roland
salle féministe de même patriarcale et
je prends une maîtresse seul seuil arcal
de mes fesses
ouais aller
montebourg n'a pas les anglais
[Musique]
parce que ça veut dire qu'on peut dire
que c'est un mauvais deuxième
[Applaudissements]
allez on voit la patte mais bon voilà
vous m'arrêtez sa ferme et là c'est quoi
votre problème
ils nous passent jamais la balle tout ce
qu'ils font c'est s'arranger pour qu'on
tombe
ces grosses tâches à quoi ça sert de
jouer si c'est pour avoir mal c'est ça
le sport mimi traitement spécial bon
alors on peut vous tapez dans les
noisettes et philippe al'inverse ils
nous donnent des coups de coude dans les
seins et c'est douloureux
c'est juste toi sat et hypersensible on
peut pas jouer avec elle
ok bon les gars partir de maintenant à
chaque fois vous recevez une balle vous
devez faire une passe office est
d'accord et un talent et son ballon et
je vous écoute de la danse on peut
danser de la violence de la torre jeu
pourrait diriger le court ouais c'est ça
moi ça me paraît une bonne idée c'est
dans ce tout le monde doit danser les
filles et les garçons
tu auras tu seras en charge de la classe
que novartis a vu juste pour un sou en
caisse
c'est un cours de trop facile de décider
[Musique]
allez en ligne tout le monde et 1 2 3 4
5 6 ap
victor1 tu sais où est ta main droite
j'espère donc de ce côté il ya ton pied
droit j'ai raison ou je me trompe mais
alors tempier doit sortir du cercle
au même moment où tes bras font comme ça
victor c'est très bien non vous êtes
près 5 6 16 bits et un stop stop stop
stop
vous n'êtes pas synchro écoutez 5 6 7 8
et juste après il y as appris vite après
8 et 9
après 8,8 et puis un au caire où cinq
six sept huit et un deux trois quatre
cinq six sept vies bravo y est tu bois
du corps c'est facile je dois maintenant
vous allez refaire son nez dans mes
lacets mettant les restes ici mon sens
je pense hélas et je compte et 5 6 7 8
et schaaf 2 6 3 6 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 fais toi
moi avance pourquoi
on recommence je compte 5 6ème lit pas
mérité ça allait fils toro comment 5 6 7
8 6 7 est en toi voilà c'était et poule
c'est pas un combat de boxe ici t'es pas
obligé de rentrer coups partent une
fatigue laisse tomber tes épaules
détends toi et les amuse toi comme une
femme à petit nous d aller tout le monde
encore une fois et cette fois avec la
musique tu es prêt à rien 6 ème but
[Musique]
ça
un câble
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
c'est une classe sympas ils ont appris
ça dans ma classe
c'est l'heure du changement
moi ça leur fera beaucoup de bien
[Musique]
salut
à
le grand gagnant des contes ancestraux
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire
5 si c'est lui 1 2 3 4 secondes à sidy
seck lui 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4
ça m'a séduit
[Applaudissements]
les free trois beaux mais rien pour nous
qui sont pas d'âme et puis ça dans mon
goût
tu as réussi à
besson
ouais
ski
c'est pourquoi
je veux qu est pourquoi nous nous
arrêter allez vas-y quoi la musique
alors nous allons faire un petit test
pour voir ce que vous avez retenu cette
année celle là quels sont les produits
d'exportation suède rome - je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait une autre selma est ce
que je me trompe pas c'était quoi la
question tu m'écoutes mimi qu'est-ce que
j'ai demandé et quelles sont nos
produits d' expertise à sion des
expertises à sion on se concentra peu
c'était la question c'est évident que
non à l'importation exportation je pense
en avoir parlé l'at-elle d'aider les
exportations c'est tout ce qu'on a en
trop et qu'on revend est-ce que je peux
avoir un exemple l'amour ce serait
génial
selma est ce qu'on peut rester dans le
sujet s'il te plaît on a vraiment trop
d'amour à revendre ensuite doit en
importer
mais c'est quoi l'amour c'est un truc de
filles le titre est bien d'en exporter
de temps en temps toi c'est quoi
vraiment l'amour est comme ça c'est quoi
l'amour tout le monde sait ce que ça
peut être un tas de trucs relais est ce
que tu peux leur demander de se taire
s'il vous plaît je vous devez arriver
demain de choses comme quand tu es d'une
vieille à descendre du bus s'arrêteront
au lieu de les pousser soumises c'est la
différence entre l'amour et la haine y a
plus qu'à espérer que le monde n'est pas
remplie de haine c'est comme l'eau et la
nourriture
tu savais où les qu'il n'y a que 2 % de
look et potable et que 1,5 pour cent est
coincé sous location mais comme il se
trouve que les glaciers il fonde on
pourrait récupérer cette eau là et et on
pourrait la mettre dans les bateaux et
l'envoyer aux pays d'afrique
c'est cette route pour la france mais ce
n'est pas le sujet du cours aujourd'hui
ce serait possible de le faire signer
une pétition pour envoyer des gens sur
la lune alors qu'il ya des gens qui
meurent de soif
non mais maire ole c'est quoi le rapport
à toutes ces bombes et ses roquettes et
ses missiles on dirait des pénis volant
ses toiles
ai-je peur que tu te calmes ont changé
leurs fusées dans l'espace
tout le monde le regarde ton plus vite
me disais c'est de l'argent m'a foutu en
l'air j'ai jamais rien entendu d'aussi
pathétique
bah ça c'est un truc d'hommes et se
croient tout permis mais c'est parce
qu'ils sont fainéants qui connaît l'île
on voit alors super membres dans
l'espace et le monde se met à jouer en
fait nous avons parlé mais comme plus
d'imaginer ce qu'on pourrait faire avec
l'argent qu'ils dépensent là dedans des
collèges privés gratuit explique moussa
ou alors des accès aux de l'emprunt
comme je vous ai expliqué à mon sens
quasi sûr pour les icebergs a sauvé le
boulet et non mais ça devient con avoir
au rwanda bon ça suffit la croix rouge
se calme on est sage est-ce que je peux
m'en tienne quoi j'ai posé une question
à selma mégi répandue si elle veut être
président du vote pour elle au président
de l'afic lisait dans les petites
grosses la barre
mais la réponse que tu attends sûrement
c'est le bois et le cerf merci il était
temps magnus est ce que tu peux me
donner des exemples de ce qu'on est
vraiment mortel dans cette classe ce
serait que ce soit nous qui te posions
les questions qui nous intéresse ce
serait trop cool par exemple comment on
fait pour faire une pétition hier c'est
ça ouais ras-le-bol au je vous demande
d'être un peu plus responsable en classe
les filles j'ai posé une question à
magnus en valeur magnus à par
l'exportation de bois et de fer
un autre exemple la pensée même pas qui
décide si on investit d'incessants place
et c'est pas forcément ceux qu'on croit
les responsables
c'est grave s'il vous plaît
mesdemoiselles vous arrêtez
d'interrompre le cours et que ça ne
devienne pas une habitude
comment c'est trop injuste ce serait
tellement plus cool si on pouvait parler
de choses qui nous intéresse ça mettrait
un peu de piment dans cette classe tu as
tellement répété tout court qu'on dirait
que même toi tu as l'heure pas digne et
de retirer même chose c'est penser que
ces cours on les oublie aussi vite que
ça forcément il s'en fout de ce qu'il
raconte
ça suffit j'en ai ma ministère et celui
d'attaquant partez maintenant si c'est
le mal on a fait quoi et sur quelle vous
sortez de cette classe je ne veux pas un
mois yes tort de distribuer aux autres
le test sur un imac ou sept cents us
quand tu as faire plus clair on s'est un
peu d'ordre et d'autorité lisez le texte
et répondez aux questions qu'est ce que
tu fais bout tu es injuste alors je
rentre chez moi
est-ce que tu as un problème je dois
étudier
[Musique]
vous jouez à quoi c'est quoi ce foutoir
maintenant une minute tout le monde veut
partir à ses yeux et je veux qu'on
m'écoute ça suffit maintenant
et c'est valable pour toi aussi saga je
voudrais suivre le programme et j'y
arriverai mieux celle je ne sais pas
pourquoi tu t'amuses à faire en sorte
que tout se passe mal mais ce n'est pas
fini
tu peux être sûr qu'on en reparlera et
maintenant tu t'assois et y les autres
aussi à 6
on n'est pas dans une classe de
maternelle pourquoi nous j'ai dit ah si
je les dis à elle si je dois me répéter
j'appelle le principal de l'école dur
maintenant n'ont pas toutes les filles
asseyez-vous c'est juste pour les autres
mais me tairai ce linda thomas seulement
tu restes là je ne veux pas rester
tu ne veux pas tu veux pas rester je ne
suis pas épanoui merci au revoir
salut les filles c'est ça la prochaine
bon on fait quoi là maintenant signer ça
bakaba restée
la ville aurait parié
[Musique]
on a fait part de plusieurs plein de ces
jours ci ça me préoccupe
on dit qu il se passe des choses dans
les classes vous êtes qu'on peut
qualifier de que de sabotage ou
rébellion jamais vous n'avez agit ainsi
avant vos professeurs sont perturbées
ils disent que l'atmosphère devient
étouffante ils n'arrivent plus à donner
leurs cours et à tenir leurs classes
s'il n'y a plus d'esprit d'équipé
c'est le chaos et vous comporter un peu
comme une meute anarchiste
même les meilleurs éléments de cette
classe sont devenus un peu irresponsable
je sais qu'il ya toujours un meneur dans
ce genre d'affaires c'est une constante
mais il faut aussi des moutons
poursuivre sa petite armée s'accordent
son groupe quelque chose à dire je vous
rappelle à tout que c'est votre dernière
année de collège il faut penser aux
diplômes et à votre avenir
ce que vous faites aujourd'hui détermine
qui vous serez demain à vous de voir
nous étions vraiment ravis d'organiser
cette excursion au printemps avec toute
l'école comme nous attendions aussi le
bal de promo je devrais les annuler si
vous ne changez pas d'attitude ou si
j'entends encore des plein devenir des
professeurs j'ai une question
oui oui c'est courant et si les
punitions collectives
rien d'autre ne semble fonctionner dans
ce cas précis saga c'est malheureusement
la seule option qui nous restent si nous
voulons que vous repreniez toutes vos
esprits et que tout rentre dans l'ordre
bien mesdemoiselles
je crois qu on s'est compris
oh
dégagé c est quatre gars vous êtes des
soldats mentale des lesbiennes antilles
ou et terroristes allaient souffrir tout
vous avez été tués tout plein de cette
école
saler l'eau des
j'ai dit salut des ouais ça lui l'outil
j'ai un truc à dire il faut que je te
parle d'un truc et baccouche
on est ok super on ira peut-être pas
faire le voyage scolaire
quoi et peut-être même le bal de fin
d'année
pourquoi j'en sais rien mais ils sont
pas droit d'annuler sa pourtant
mais pourquoi
pour les troubles
[Musique]
je viens
il
[Musique]
ce fut le début de la fin à moins que
c'est commencé bien avant on se rend pas
compte quand on le vit on pensait qu'on
était tous dans le même bateau que nos
vies changent et mais que tout était
figée que tout le monde était contre
nous et on n'avait pas l'habitude d'être
attaquée de toutes parts les garçons les
professeurs tout le monde
[Musique]
on a eu peur
[Rires]
oui
saga c'est quand qu'on baise quand je te
vois je pense plus à rien je veux te
sauter peux pas te faire baiser
quand tu parles j'entends rien parce que
je pense juste à te démonter je suis
capable
oui
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
entrée
pas de cours aujourd'hui
vous travaillerez salle ou lycées de la
page 102 à la page 120 et vous répondez
aux questions c'est carrément beaucoup
trop long ce vendredi après midi
olé est-ce qu'on peut le faire à la
maison et une rendre lundi plutôt sans
déconner bordel c'est vendre ventus le
test en cours vous me rendrez vos copies
en sortant je veux voir de quoi vous
êtes capable sans mon aide
c'est chier c'est tout allait commencer
et que je l'étais mais je suis vraiment
très doué pour ça non sérieux passent le
moins qu'estimé troc ou est ce que vous
pouvez faire confiance
ça y est les coûts dit merci
si tu veux je m'occupe aussi du tien
j'adore faire ça
ton petit truc et tout en mêlée c'est
parce que je voulais dire je parles de
tes écouteurs en fait tout est de
trouver la fermer bravo merci mais
sérieux depuis quand ils nous donnent
des ordres du ha j'ai juste demandé tu
as pas à nous dire ce qu'on doit faire
mais on essaie juste de se concentrer
pour le test parce que tu crois
sérieusement tu peux arriver à un
certain tu rêves éveillés c'est quoi son
délire
j'ai pas au lait 1 tu peux pas leur dire
stop
on a ainsi qu'avant dans la glace et tu
peux rester dans ton coin saga et la
soirée quoi vous étiez là s'il te plaît
saga lâche du lest si tu veux bien
laisse tomber sa gare laisse tomber que
je lâche du lest tout est un problème ou
une injustice pour toi saga arrête de
faire ta justice il prend trop le chou
pourquoi tu prends tout comme c'est la
terre entière et est contre toi parce
que c'est loin de la vérité
en revanche nous apprécierions au
vraiment tout ce que tu ailles régler
des problèmes personnels qui nous
empoisonnent ailleurs que dans cette
classe je peux te prendre rendez-vous
avec le médiateur de l'école située
plutôt avec le psy s'il vous plaît
reprenez vos stylos tu m'as donné une
mission tu t'en rappelles tu m'as
demandé clairement des délais fille a
trouvé leur place c'est bien ce que tu
as dit mais tu n'as pas vraiment envie
que ça change
pas plus que les élèves écoutent ces
gars je te libère de cette mission que
tu a foiré ça n'en sera que mieux rien
tu n'as rien amélioré en classe en fait
c'est même l'un verse la situation a
complètement dégénéré
sega
tu n'es qu'un seul hypocrite
je sais pas quoi
elle a dit vrai c'était un seul pot
creed
tu le sais nous aussi on le sait que sa
guérison on est tous des lâches
ce qu'elle a dit est vrai personne ne
parle jamais des problèmes parce qu'on
est tous une bande de lâches et toi le
premier des grands lacs faibles et
inutiles
on évite tous complètement vide
[Musique]
saga je veux te dire quelque chose me
dire quoi je veux te dire que je peux te
dire que le jeu habitude sui te dire que
je retenais pas comme les autres
comment tu sais que je le dis a tant de
mal à dire ça
saga n'est jamais revenu à l'école
personne n'osait vraiment en parler
on sait tous inquiétés mais elle n'a
répondu à aucun coup de fil ni aucun sms
pourquoi elle l'aurait fait on l'a
laissé tomber
[Musique]
moi
mais quelque chose a changé en une
petite lumière s'est allumée
je suis toujours timide mais je n'ai
plus peur saga nous a changé mais ça
nous a effrayé
j'avais senti ce changement et je me
déteste d'avoir été si lâche même si
j'avais été plus forte que les autres
je croyais être une poule mouillée une
trouillarde mais c'est pas vrai je le
sais maintenant
[Musique]
non
c
salut
des chercher du sel oui j'étais envoyé
un tas de messages
je m'en vais demain tu vas où
ocaña pour le travail ne peut pas tenir
il planche sur un nouveau projet ça va
être un super projet c'est une école à
temps
tiens les aux enfants mais c'est
vraiment ce sont des styles en gentil il
y en a assez pour une petite classe
[Musique]
on
comment va lui toujours aussi nul comme
avant
[Musique]
pourrait bien
je te souhaite beaucoup de bonnes choses
au kenya toi aussi aux ici
[Musique]
je n'oublierai jamais
oh
prends soin de toi
[Musique]
et
on
à cet instant très précis les routes se
séparent pour se connecter à d'autres
à cet instant très précis j'ai accès au
monde entier
je peux aller où je veux je le peux
vraiment je vais devenir mille fois plus
forte
[Musique]
je te donne mon adresse mail sagara
hotmail.com
e
[Musique]
oh
d
[Musique]